come on bro we can make out later baby
and your sexy look at that why not for
her or network bro bro tell me you look
so good and think so
my name is pigs bud let's go let's go
pity I'm sorry about everything sorry
about making out with him in front of
you and still doing it so doing some
sexual things for them you know my heart
belongs to you pity you know that you
know I only want you I mean I'm asleep
look at me
almost like like I mean hey I'm totally
it's like Camila
oh don't pull the leverage me gay boom
sorry sorry honestly is what I do what I
do
so sexual snakish
have you ever seen a pig being sexual
like this [ __ ] sorry I keep doing
this stuff when I don't know what to do
or where to go
perhaps a masher or but can be used for
great harmony on technique I don't know
what that means I don't know where that
grant ran out this totally looks like oh
maybe it's yellow are you yellow yellow
yellow yellow yellow it's only this one
what do you think piggy I don't know I'm
just Pig I mean a snake looks like I'm a
[ __ ]
is this a swamp but I pull it and bashed
off happen I don't want to do it I just
don't want to do it I just other's
numbers oh [ __ ] I didn't notice I didn't
even mean to do it
[ __ ] oh that was a
what you want huh it's really annoying
like when you can't run it's sad it's
just sad that I died
I'm still in this room obviously I've
been something about the correct Oh
they'd been in there maybe I can use my
masher or no [ __ ] light let's go back
oh the police no the great underground I
can't go back I can't go back I can't go
back what this is mushroom glowing
mushrooms even though they help me right
now why do I use the are mushrooms
everywhere I even leave this place I
don't know I can't huh
mushrooms build this place mushrooms I
don't understand what sad girl weird
mushroom
oh I wasted my own why didn't you tell
me
ah I don't have anyone lap are you happy
all the things I do for you guys
spire accounts your opinions by Ark
experimental family there's something
I'm missing in the experimental film way
I just sing or my hunch mine alone
throws that row right be doing
make me flower it's like in the flower
how you like licking the floor huh hi
like nobody's love it's not fair I don't
like flow enjoy is every time everything
you like looking for huh you like doing
backflips hmm
you like doing backflips hmm hmm you
like doing backflips I don't know what
to do
I pull this I don't have anywhere I go
there it's like forever great on the
ground which is great on the ground I
don't mind one
maybe I pull everyone besides oh we good
digging Peggy no good we good we good
problem hmm problem no no there's a
problem you just don't don't make me do
backflips I ain't backflips okay this
one problem problem Peggy Peggy it's
your problem
oh there's a problem I'm sneaky no
problem no problem Peter no
under struttin that ass struttin that
ass turn it turn it
okay good good pink one problem problem
problem problem everywhere ah hi stuck
oh okay it was okay remember not the
pink like lots of friends here having
fun having fun gang banging and weird
ways think you go over their problem
their problem their problem
another bro it's this one and this one
that I can't touch so I would assume
that I'm doing the right thing here even
though it's probably it's the wrong
thing problem whoa what are you guys
doing here
series it off piggy you're a [ __ ] you're
a sloth piggy
do you see
[Music]
how do oh never mind I knew that I no
problem
are you [ __ ] kidding me secret groom
found yet
what are they [ __ ] coincidence that I
said problem a million times and then
find a [ __ ] troll face I honestly had
no idea that would happen
holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] that's awesome
that's how Allah whoever made this it's
like maybe I made this game I mean what
else would pull levers and say problems
and then fine
problem faced I'm so mind [ __ ] up so
mine [ __ ] I don't know what oh ah this
is seriously freaking me out
I did the right thing
oh [ __ ] I'm soaked up yells I'm like a
14 year old [ __ ] I what
that was seriously some weird [ __ ]
problem wow this is [ __ ] well
the [ __ ] is all I had to say that [ __ ]
[ __ ] everywhere
[Music]
oh I thought it was loading [ __ ]
something is blocking the door or maybe
this barrier this come on
I using the [ __ ] or what do you want
come on
I thought a solid maybe yeah
maybe this piece of [ __ ]
[Music]
it's so calming and sweet
meatballs seriously let's talk at me
what happens if I go in here though
happy face
Ferro on his happy face yeah we're so
happy now I'm with Suzy oh I don't
understand
1/4 mile big it tell me what to do I'm
Bob but I don't know what to do I'm so
pumped but I've no idea what's up um I
come home them on the bump the mom okay
that's enough to eat on the secret
[ __ ] room I can't figure out how to
solve this possible
maybe we go back inside the other place
or at home like I don't know I'm Robert
I'm here maybe aren't some very sexual
if you are permitted
[Music]
that
forget what I was saying I'm sorry oh
[ __ ]
like a [ __ ] email by the power of
Grayskull
yes strong
- I'm [ __ ] seung-ah Grayskull
whatever
yes amen
Christendom here
but you can never too many times
mushrooms
same
it's probably not in here just probably
not Papa I admittedly this is a balanced
way
I did the Bravo
I'll rap
nothing doing
is it's not in here [ __ ] I don't know
what though though maybe we go back
somewhere there's your MS maybe maybe
I'm just saying what I'm thinking here
trying to connect with you again you
feel the connection
you want the connection
maybe alcohol okay let's go back to
where we find the oranges I'm out of
eels
I'm I never work
let's go
too many sexual jokes in the last 30
minutes I think I should try to come
down holy [ __ ] who threw that so wrong
and right
yeah scary stuff
Oh
one
great like oh man
not the stats it can't be up there it's
impossible really
my visit to where it's so [ __ ] dark I
literally see nothing oh this games
awesome the graphics are amazing come on
give me something
nope I'm stuck I need you here so the
next episode leave comment tell me what
you to sorry that's a little stupid
anyway thanks for humming up this video
I'll see you next time bye my name's
Hannah back bye bye
yo ask me what it feel like staring at
the sky so Vendela telling Kurt Russell
homie this ain't real life I'll be
making good on my promises honesty is
pop it inside of it is missing but I
realized I could be better than I was
lighter on my feet cooking up the soul
when we fire up